her coming up in the lingerie humanize
things for you
i think it did for me because it's like
i'm nervous so when i see her i'm like
she's got to be a little bit nervous but
she was super confident and i'm like
dang i like that a lot matt james
first question i got to ask you my
friend chris harrison told me
you haven't really ever seen this show
is that true before you became the
bachelor you hadn't seen it
i thought you would have watched your
friend tyler cameron on hannah b's
season of the bachelorette
you know what i i absolutely did there
was uh
it was tough though because i see tyler
a certain way so when i watched it
i didn't want my view of him to be
distorted but
uh that wasn't the case and i'm hoping
that's not the case for me either
uh by the way you know fans still want
tyler and hannah b to get back together
you think that's going to happen
well you got to ask them about that i
can't speculate on that
what advice did they give you about
going on the show
they were they were huge i mean
especially you know hannah
that relationship that we formed during
quarantine she was she was awesome
and um she just told me to be myself it
sounds
simple but when you're in that moment
it's
it's easy to kind of get caught up in
the moment but um
i continued to do things that grounded
me which was exercise eat healthy
pray and i got through it we hear that
you have
never been in love so did you fall in
love as the bachelor
that's a great question you know i love
to me look different before i got to
nemacon because
of what i experienced up into that point
and yeah i guess i'd say i could i
hadn't experienced love until
until until i got out there you know
some fans have questioned matt
if you're ready for marriage because
they saw you and tyler cameron hanging
out together in new york having fun
are you ready for marriage absolutely
you know that's why i came out there
and um i don't think that
anyone is more so ready or not it's
something that
you just know when you experience it
well you know your parents are not
together you talk about that in the
premiere how you didn't see this marital
love growing up
how did that affect you that was huge i
mean that's
was kind of a crutch uh coming into this
it's like
i don't want to force something i don't
want to put myself in a situation to to
hurt somebody or be hurt
and that was a realization i came
through the came to during quarantine is
that
you're never going to be more so or less
so ready to
to experience this you just got to go
into it and do it and i'm glad i did
well of course you are
the first black bachelor what kind of
pressure did you feel
taking on this role and where was it
coming from if any i felt a lot you know
i'm not gonna lie
that uh it was a lot
lauren but uh the more conversations i
had with chris and and he really helped
me
realize that you know i i only speak for
myself
and my experience is my own
and when someone has an opinion whether
they're white or black that's their
opinion it doesn't
mean that all black or white people
think that way and i think i did a great
job representing
how i was raised and where i come from
and and what i'm looking for and i hope
that people see that too
well race was a big topic on tasha
adams's recent season
how much does it come up for you in your
talks with the women and maybe how much
did you want it to come up if at all
i think it's important you know uh it's
it's something that everyone should talk
about because it's what we're
experiencing
and um if you're white if you're black
like our kids are gonna look a certain
type of way and they're gonna go through
what i've been through so i think it's
absolutely important and something that
we talked about a lot
we see a little little in the promo i do
acknowledge color in every sense i think
that they like
love is love it doesn't matter what it
looks like i potentially found
the person who's going to change the
world with me the work you're doing is
going to shape a generation
you started your season with a prayer we
see that in the premiere
why did you want to do that what tone
did you want to set i just wanted uh
well first and foremost i was extremely
nervous you know i was shaking walking
up there like i was like
i wanted chris to walk me inside you
know and he left me so i'm just walking
in there
and whenever i'm i'm feeling that type
of way or anxious i'm just like man let
me pray about this
and uh and that's what i did and it put
me at ease
and um i'm hoping that the women saw
that
and i just wanted them to see where i go
to in my times of anguish and when i'm
stressed out so
that was that's what that was you were
nervous matt what made you so nervous
you seem like a confident guy
well you know it again when
it's all you know there's you're sitting
there
with your buddies and you're like well i
would go about it this way and then you
get in that room and you see these
beautiful women all
dressed up and it's just like i'm at a
loss for words you know i don't know
i'm seeing a big dildo on the on the
counter i'm
trying to keep my train of thought i
don't know what to say um
but yeah the woman made me nervous you
know they brought it how much does
religion come into play because we just
saw tasha and a relationship over it on
the show
that's a great question you know i uh my
views are my own and i would never force
that on somebody
especially those views being different
within my family you know
my brother and i uh have completely
different uh
religious beliefs and i don't love him
any less and
i would never want that to be something
that kept me from being with somebody
it's just
um yeah well what are give me three
non-negotiables of yours three things a
woman cannot be or have if you're gonna
date her
three non-negotiables uh honesty
uh we can't have any we got to be able
to trust each other so
if you're a liar that's that's a
non-starter
um let's see that's one two
um spicy food like my i have my
stomach's all jacked if
if you're doing throwing a bunch of
spices in there where we're eating crazy
like
uh it it's probably gonna be a
non-starter for them because i'm gonna
be all gassy so
uh the spicy food is gonna be hard uh
and then the last thing
uh someone who's gotta be able to laugh
you gotta be able to laugh at yourself
uh because life's too short to take
everything so serious so someone i can
have fun with you gotta be able to have
a good time all right i love that matt
you're the first lead ever to give me
spicy food as an answer to that question
i love it
milestones milestones matt um by the way
how much i want to get into how much
this season was kind of a milestone for
you in your life
we see you crying on the curb with chris
harrison in this promo you're crying
you're saying where do i go from here
tease that moment for me what's
happening there
one of the things that's been hard for
me and my relationships
is going deep and sharing who i am what
i'm about
and what i've been through because it
opens up this place
that scares me and i think about my mom
i think about my brother and how this
broken family and broken marriage has
affected their lives
and i don't want to put anybody through
that lauren i mean
the the i'll say this
there's things in my personal life that
i try to avoid
which are uncomfortable conversations
conversations about your family
conversations about
your feelings just like as a man that's
been a hard thing for me to have so when
you have to address those things that
have held you back
in relationships past that type of
emotion comes out
and i had to address it and that type of
emotion came out you know
chris told us that there's a lot of
depth to you a lot of emotional baggage
that people don't know about
how much do you get into that and how
much does it change you doing the show
does it break you down as a person
a thousand percent you know it it really
did break me down
i uh there was a lot of conversations
that i had that i needed to have
that i hadn't had and i wasn't planning
on having
uh but that's where this this whole
experience took me and i'm so fortunate
for it because i grew as a man
and uh it allowed me to be vulnerable
for these women and open up so that
i could experience what i've experienced
wow so different guy now than before you
started filming
a thousand percent have you matured have
you grown have you changed what would
you describe it as
i don't think it's a maturity thing it's
more so me taking ownership of
those experiences like like being
not being being okay with where i'm at
and not
having something that doesn't
necessarily have to deal with me holding
me back
and uh not to give too much away but
we'll get into that
as the season rolls on and you'll see
some work we're holding me back in my
relationship like that
head on so are you no longer being held
back it seems like you're looking at
love differently
is filming the most you've ever cried we
see you crying a good amount in these
promos
that's a great question i i don't i
can't recall calling crying that much
but it's it feels good to cry like
crying like there's nothing wrong with
crying
and and it's an emotion and like this
whole journey is emotional
and uh when when you when you get the
form and feelings like i have for these
women throughout the process like
it's inevitable all right well let's
talk about a couple of these women real
quick we have an exclusive sneak peek
of kylie who meets you in lingerie on
night one
will that entrance get her far i
realized i don't know anything about
you so what better opportunity
to figure out what you like than to ask
for your opinion on what i should
wear yeah i think you'd look great in
anything you wear but i kind of like the
strapless
okay yeah i like that i mean like she is
literally in brawn underwear
at least she has a robe on oh man that
was
you're seeing women come out of limo so
i'm just like i'm programmed and
i'm like all right then that's what i'm
gonna come up and then i see this
drop dead gorgeous woman come up with
i'm like wait
i'm just dying laughing because again
these type of things that are happening
just humanize it and it's like okay like
this isn't normal when her coming up in
the lingerie humanize things for you
i think it did for me because it's like
i'm nervous so when i see her i'm like
she's got to be a little bit nervous but
she was super confident and i'm like
damn i like that a lot speed round with
some of the standout women from night
one
abigail she gets your first impression
rose how into abigail are you abigail
i mean i don't i don't even know where
to start like there's not a bad thing to
say about her i mean she's
she's incredible rachel you say she blew
you away
how far do things go with rachel i just
love her honestly you know she
is someone who was clear-cut about why
she was there from night one
three first girl to get your rose at the
ceremony how much do you like bree
again bree uh first thing she cheered me
out of the limo was super heartfelt and
i just loved that message
and it was it felt real so i i liked
that a lot a
kit we noticed you watched her walk away
up the stairs what attracts you to kit
it's fiery you know she's super
confident in who she is and where she
comes from and she owns it and i love
that
and katie katie brings what we'll call a
special friend a toy to the house
matt what's going through your mind
with with that when you start i was man
i was just hoping it was clean because
she's waving at my face and stuff i'm
just like man
we gotta make sure that you know what i
mean we were it was it was a lot
i think viewers might have a strong
reaction to that item's presence
on night one what would you say to
viewers about it if they're offended or
if they think it's funny what do you
think
i think that uh again it gets back to
you can't please everybody and i thought
it was funny you know it's it's who she
is like that's how she wanted to come
and represent herself
and um i thought it was awesome like she
was comfortable doing something like
that
and i'm not going to shame her for that
i was that was dope like it was it was
super
it you know it's a icebreaker she named
it mj
well you know that was very generous to
her but that
that that was that's yeah what a moment
yeah okay i gotta wrap up with you soon
but more women are gonna join later
including heather martin and one who is
allegedly a paid escort
what can you tease about that how much
does that shake things up
i it shakes things up a lot
it shakes things up a lot also what
happened to your finger you okay
oh my gosh i freaking this is like such
a guy thing like i don't have band-aids
i had
to take my finger i cut it when i was
cleaning the blender and i'm like
you would have thought i got cut by a
samurai sword that goes for one of those
healthy smoothies and are you sticking
with the beard
i like it it's cold up here it's cold in
new york i gotta get something to
insulate the heat so
it's been it's been a nice change-up all
right matt well just real quick just
describe your season for me in a couple
words if you can
chris harrison told me that if we think
you've got a six-pack when it comes to
emotions
it's an eight or a twelve pack
oh man um
it was it was a lot of letting
not only my my walls down but these
women letting their their walls down and
being extremely vulnerable
and myself included
went places had conversations that i
never thought i'd ever have
and we all came out better people and
you were shirtless plenty matt and
did you mind because i don't think the
audience is going to complain
yeah i was i didn't mind it was it was
it was it was great weather up there so
i didn't mind you know i got a little
tan
all right matt james thank you so much
for joining us and will we see tyler
cameron pop by
hannah brown that's a great question he
was my best friend i wouldn't be
surprised if you know he i don't know
he might i don't know he was i'd have my
phone so i couldn't
all right matt james is your season of
the bachelor here to save 2021
you know i don't want to put a lot of
expectations on it but i think it's a
great start to the year i think it's
gonna be a great start to the year